joseph nos miss c'est lui à 73 ans
l'homme est ému jusqu'aux larmes une
forte émotion qui le tenaille
il empêche de s'exprimer devant notre
caméra ou pas bien le cloud qui s'abat
ko toujours les chocolats nous sommes au
quartier monnaie ou françois la soupe à
marie mobilisés pour soutenir joseph nos
miss dont la maison a été détruite en
début de semaine suite à une décision de
justice
la maison en question la voici prise en
photo en 2001 pour un magazine
spécialisé dans le tourisme
on voit la maison au fond on voit la
plage nettoyée
comme toujours parce que je ne jouais
pas de bruit là est la brigade du
littoral peut être témoin de sa située
sur les cinquante pas géométriques
joseph nomi 7,1 occupants sans titre
depuis 1936 nous dit il malgré dix ans
de procédure il n'a pas obtenu sa
régularisation
une injustice pour la soupe a mal à sa
décision injuste et criminels passent
hommage au talent et pour bénéficier
mais sinon c'est tout bénéfique mais au
talent de sera grillé en occupation
historique parce que il a avant 1980
1981 est une des maisons qui arrive et
après 1981 qui alentours y dorment pas
dénoncer poignant mans en discrimination
qui est haché prétendre à dénoncer ça
dans un communiqué la ville du françois
rappelle avoir soutenu joseph nos miss
dans ces démarches si elle souligne
également que la situation des occupants
sans titre de la zone des 50 pas doit
être étudiée est traité de manière
équitable